the Joe Rogan experience well you know I
there's a kid named John Gotti the third
is John Gotti the gangsters grandson
yeah he's an MMA fighter oh no [ __ ] it's
good
no [ __ ] good yeah Wow so far he's
fighting on these small promotions but
he's [ __ ] people up Wow jacked Wow
yeah yeah I remember John cuz I lived on
Mulberry Street in little E's and it was
a [ __ ] tenement apartment and
downstairs literally downstairs and one
door over was the ravenite social club
which was where Gotti met on Wednesday
nights yeah all the bosses would pull up
and the the Capo's and I don't know the
terms but they lined up [ __ ] limos
usual Berry Street oh yeah they walk up
and down the street smoking cigars and
John Gotti junior was kind of in charge
at that time which I guess would be this
guy's father yes and he parent wasn't
known as being that sharp well the
family's thing kind of fell apart since
then I don't think there's I think the
FBI just had unlimited resources
government backing and they slowly
picked the [ __ ] organization apart
and then it's got people to rat on each
other they bugged the ravenite social
club they got inside and they bugged it
and then when they found out it was
bugged the the wiseguys would walk up
and down Mulberry Street and talk about
their business so they sold the cars on
the route they bugged the hubcaps of the
cars on the route you heard about that
yeah well that was always the thing
about that guy the chin what's-his-name
the chin Gigi auntie how the [ __ ] they
say his name Vincent the chin and he was
crazy but he wasn't crazy but he would
act crazy so you'd walk around the
bathroom right yes he was up on trial he
was out on bail yeah just right wander
through the streets with a bathrobe on
playing crazy that's him just walking
around I'm crazy bug Tim - that'd be fun
to pretend you're crazy I think he was
actually the guy that they got with the
hubcaps oh yeah maybe what maybe they
used that tactic more than once yes guys
you know they they had a [ __ ]
neighborhood where they would go to and
when they were in that neighborhood that
was their their territory right
like when you were living there was that
going on like god he was out of jail no
yeah but they still showed up mostly
guys I think I think they're really
headquarters is more in Brooklyn but
they still came back to Mulberry Street
and it is literally across the street
was Saint Patrick's School which is
where Robert De Niro and Scorsese went
to school as kids and we're you remember
the film Mean Streets
yeah that was shot remember they jump
over the wall into the cemetery that's
that's Saint Patrick's School it's
across from the ravenite social club
[ __ ] I don't remember anything about
that movie I remember the movie but I
don't remember anything about what
happened I need to see that one again
yeah I need to see that one again
[Applause]